in life it's a very simple principle but
all success comes from completing tasks
fully functioning people these at the
top 10% of people never complain and
never explain if you're stuck in a
dead-end job that you can't leave
because you have no money set aside you
have put a break on your potential
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from motivational
speaker author and sales expert Brian
Tracy and my take on his top ten rules
of success volume 2 rule number 2 is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one that you guys like the best
and as always guys if you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
act as if you already had the goal that
you desire so let us say for example you
want to be financially independent you
want to be financially successful how
would you behave if you are financially
successful how would you dress how would
you organize your life how would you
treat other people sometimes I say
imagine that you are financially
independent you're independently wealthy
and you're only doing your current job
as a courtesy to your boss and to keep
yourself busy during the day but
basically an extremely wealthy person
you've inherited an enormous amount of
money from some source how would you
behave if you were already the wealthy
person that your desire to be many
people don't realize that if you if you
behave like a poor person there's an old
saying that poor people poor folks have
poor ways if you behave like a poor
person you'll always be poor if you
dress like a bum if you have a messy
home or apartment if your car is dirty
with junk in the backseat that's how
poor people live and what happens or
you're surrounding yourself with the
image of being poor and you cannot
change your outer world until your
change your inner world ask yourself
what are the three most important things
that I do in my work and then you have
to discipline yourself to start with the
most important tasks and work on that
task until it is complete and it's a
very simple principle but it is the
beginning and the middle and the end of
success decide on your most important
task begin immediately and work on that
task with self-discipline until it is
100% complete in life it's a very simple
principle but all success comes from
completing tasks it's not from working
at tasks it's from completing tasks it
is only when you complete tasks that you
are successful the the most important
key to success is to start and complete
one important task
first thing in the morning if you eat
the Frog eat the Frog if you try to do
many things you end up doing that
so you make a list of all your work
before you begin and then you ask if I
could only do one thing on this list
which one activity is the most important
and then you do that activity only that
until it's complete if you start every
day by completing a task you will double
and triple your productivity you will
find that every major change in your
life is accompanied by a person or
persons who either opens or closes doors
for you but possibility of your
achieving the best life for you will be
determined by the number of people who
know you and like you and who are
willing to help you now in order to
broaden your network of contacts you
must network continually at every
opportunity there seems to be a direct
relationship between the number of
people you know and how successful you
are now to network successfully the
simple strategy is this when you need a
new person ask them what they do ask for
their business card and then see if you
can't find something that you can do for
them and the one thing that people like
the most is if you can send them a
customer many people who network are
thinking what can I get from this other
person is your strategy when you meet a
new person who can be helpful to you is
to think what can I give to this person
what can I do for this person and how
quickly can I do it that way is sow
seeds of people who will be prepared to
help you in the future
the fear of rejection is caused by a
hyper concern for the opinions of other
people in William glasses work on what
they call the fully functioning person
at a wonderful line they said fully
functioning people these are the top 10
percent of people never complain and
never explain they never defend
themselves is they do it or they don't
do it but they never feel that they have
to explain themselves to anyone else if
someone doesn't like it they say and
your point is and they just don't
care and your job is to reach the point
where you say I like myself I like
myself I'm responsible for my own life
and if someone doesn't like what I do or
don't do that's their problem it's not
my problem and if you repeat this to
yourself over and over again you can
actually reprogram yourself and cancel
out an override all the previous
programming that's generating these
fears that you experience in your adult
life here's a very important story they
studied the 500 owners of the fastest
growing businesses in the world and they
asked them why did you choose this
business and all of them said I choose
this business because I really loved the
product I wanted the product for myself
and so I've developed it for myself like
the founder of eBay was looking for a
way to sell his candy dispensers he had
a collection and there wasn't anything
so he created a little auction site on
the Internet at the beginning and then
he found he could sell other things in
an auction it built eBay one of the most
successful companies in the world but he
started it because he wanted it for
himself so you'll always be successful
if you create the product or service
because here's something that you want
and believe in for yourself financial
freedom means that you're making enough
money so that you don't have to think
about it continually or best of all that
you never think about it at all
most people worry about money all the
time and that's a lousy way to live
nearly 80% of the population is
preoccupied with money problems they
think about it when they wake up and
they think about it during the day and
they think about when they go to sleep
at night and sometimes it keeps them
awake at night
the only way for you to achieve
financial freedom is for you to define
your financial goals clearly and then
make plans to achieve those goals
there's a faucet that you've heard about
called serendipity and serendipity is
defined as the
making happy discoveries is that you
find things that seem to conspire
together to bring you the things you
wanted look give me the right person you
read you like article you get the right
email or phone call and so on
it's called serendipity happy discovers
and what they found by the way this is a
common factor that you can tap into what
they found is that people who are seen
to have serendipitous wonderfully
personal experiences are people who are
characterized by one thing they're
looking nobody has a serendipitous
experience sitting there watching
television or reading the paper or
drinking in the bar in other words first
people who have these happy just babies
happy discoveries or people who are
looking and so one of the most important
requirements for success again based on
years and years of research which I've
done is ambitious and really means that
your hunger is it your hunger you want
to be successful you want to be
successful more than all same thing else
always choose higher quality rather than
lower cost
most companies think the way to sell
more is to lower the price but the true
reason for success and there's years of
research is to improve the quality of
your product you improve the quality of
your product there was a study of the
500 fastest growing companies in the
world that came out last year and they
found the number-one place where they
invested was improving the quality of
the product that if you had a certain
amount of money to invest in your
business there's not on advertising or
machinery or computers because if you
improve the quality that's the each of
success having money in the bank gives
you greater freedom and the ability to
take advantage of opportunities when
they come along if you're broke or in
debt and an opportunity comes along you
have no options open to you there's
nothing that you can do
so having money makes you free one of
the most important things I ever learned
in life is that you're only as free as
your options if you have no options if
you have to do whatever it is you're
doing you have no choice you have no
freedom if you're stuck in a dead-end
job that you can't leave because you
have no money set aside you have to put
a break on your potential you are locked
in place and you have no option for
moving forward you can end up spinning
your wheels and losing months and years
of your time by the very fact that you
have no choice but to accept whatever is
being handed to you but if you have
money they call this opportunity money
if you have money put aside you can walk
away from a bad job and you can take
time to find exactly the right job for
you
this idea of saving up money so that you
are available to take opportunities has
transformed many people's lives I
believe you with the last verse of carry
on there some who drift out in the
deserts of Delta and some who in
negativities wallow there are others I
know who in piety go because of a heaven
follow but the laborers possess it and
to give up your best for the sweetness
and joy of the giving the help folks
along with a hand and a song why there's
the real sunshine of living carry on
carry on fight the good fight and true
there's big work to do believe in your
missions greet life with a cheer there's
big work to do and that's why you're
here carry on carry on that the world be
the better for you so at last when you
die let this be your cry carry on my
soul carry on ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen if you will resolve
with whatever life hands you to carry on
there is nothing that can stop you from
achieving the greatness for which you
were created
thank you
hello this is Brian Tracy I wanted to
thank Evan for making this video and
sharing these important messages with
his audience
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top 10 check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Clyde Hays Clyde thank you so much for
picking up a couple of my book you're
one word and taking that picture of you
in the books I love it thank you for
posting it and sending it in I
appreciate the support man and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
self-awareness is a critical part of
mental health this is how you discover
why you react and respond the way you do
to people in situations around you
successful people understand themselves
and why they think and feel the way they
do and that's one of the things that you
learn when you can understand and accept
yourself you can begin moving forward in
other areas of your life your level of
ability in your field will determine the
quality and quantity of your results but
better you get at what you do
the easier is that for you to start
moving forward and to get a particular
level of results as you increase your
skill level in your field to study and
experience you get better and better at
doing the small things that increase the
speed and predictability of your results
remember skills are things that can be
developed over and over and all business
skills are learn about you can learn any
skill you need to learn to achieve any
business goal that you can set for
yourself talk to yourself positively
about the person that you want to be and
the things that you want to have when
you see a beautiful car you say I Drive
a car like that pretty soon when you see
beautiful quotes you say those are kind
of clothes I wear when you see beautiful
homes you say I'm going to live in a
house like that is keep talking to
yourself about the things that you want
to have and the person that you want to
be and each time you do you're
reprogramming and your subconscious mind
is accepting your new commands and is
working 24 hours a day to bring them
into your life just give it a try and
see what happens